he's more threes per game than at any  other point in his career going inside  this time  a little turnaround is good for lebron  james well that time he had to fade to  create enough space  not elevating high enough but space  allowed him to get a shot off a great  defense  lebron right there on eight wow he has  matched up with aidan a couple of times  this time he wins that battle schroeder  all the way  the scoop won't go there's harold with  the board  jay crowder with release out of his  hands as lebron goes up and just  smothers him takes it creates the  turnover and the lakers go down  and are going to get two free throws  with 6 38 to go  here in the first quarter